this is Halloween on this trailer
commentaries was a bonus trailer
commentaries it's not that Halloween
movie it's this Halloween movie known as
Halloween that's not even a Halloween
movie that's a whole other show that's a
whole other thing that's Dan Morello
that's just our Thanksgiving movie you
watch it exactly between that one tree
yeah
we're doing australe commentaries we're
talking about the honest trailer for
Halloween if you stick around you'll see
a little things that we cut from this
one and some cut jokes and some things
didn't make it in but until then we're
gonna talk about Halloween goofy and the
honest trailer indie yeah why are you
talking like slashing when he's mostly
actually choking women he's really not
doing much lot you know what's the deal
with babysitters what does he have
against the babysitter she seems to be
letting him do whatever he wants on that
night the carbon jack-o'-lantern and
watch the scary movies what's the big
deal yeah it's a good a good movie this
is a tough one there's not much to say
about the movie that you don't already
know it's the og slasher flick screen
it's me yeah I love this movie yeah I
think some of the best movies ever made
people laugh at me when I say that I
don't care I think it's true it's a good
ass movie thanks for most it's
definitely one of the most influential
movies ever made in the american film
history and it's one of my favorites
this is the kind I saw this was a
teenager this is the kind of movie I
love to watch with my friends mmm like I
would sit down with my friends and watch
this movie and watch them find Michael
like in the backgrounds and stuff which
is always fun the inspiration for
Where's Waldo
yeah very as a fact I just made up yeah
that'd be a good book where's Michael
although movie adaptation where it's
just different shots of crowds that's
the movie there's no plot it's literally
just actively finding him that's very
peaceful yeah what's your Halloween hot
take Joe oh man
this is a great score by John Carpenter
yeah really good score I wish she would
I'd be totally down for him to just
randomly score some movies now like I
don't think I'm gonna get my wish of him
directing like a Marvel movie or
anything anytime soon but it would be
cool if you just scored one I'll take
any I'll take it yeah yeah he's uh I
wouldn't hold your breath I read an
article I wasn't able to work into the
trailer but I was just I found it very
relatable of John Carpenter saying
basically like I don't want to make
movies I just want to play video games
and watch basketball
yeah no good for you oh yeah I feel like
this movie now suffers from because with
the new one coming out I got a lot of
people just I read a lot of comments and
a few people tweeting me sing like I
watched the first Halloween and I don't
get what the big deal is and it's it's I
call it the Citizen Kane problem where
people watch a movie that was so
groundbreaking when it came out and
inspired so many movies that the movies
that it inspired then took the things
that this movie invented and turned them
into tropes so that when a modern
audiences goes back and watches this
movie they just see the tropes without
knowing that this it invented those
things and did them so well that other
movies just a trope a I've seen there's
so many movies they've covered they've
that have so much sicker kills and
you're like
I had to start somewhere I couldn't
start with the six kill or there'd be
nowhere to go bro yeah yeah but I just I
disagree I do think Citizen Kane is a
bit of a clinical watch even for me it's
a bit it's I think that there's some
really interesting things to it but it's
also much you very much a technical
thing yeah I still think this movie
stands on its own not just as something
that had vented a lot of what came after
it but I think this is still a really
good movie I know it's a little slow for
some people I get it this fear that it's
building I think that it's just very
kind of ratcheting the tension for the
third act it's slow the second time
around the first time it is ratcheting
up the tension the second time when you
know when the killing starts it's like
wow that's a lot of teenagers doing teen
things like they're just going about the
day talking about boys and doing chores
like it takes because the real action
doesn't start you told I don't know 60
percent of the way in but the fact that
yeah I mean the first time it's he's
always he's lurking in the act ground he
like is that it's now gonna be a member
the first time when she was in the
laundry room
trashing her stuff I'm like oh she's
gonna this is it for her and no it's
just another very tension-filled thing
you know he's there that he's gone where
is he but you know yeah I agree
probably as with any horror movie once
you know where the jumps and the scares
are it's not as effective very true so
let's watch again the honest trailer for
Halloween this is Halloween the pomace
trailer commentaries
before you see Halloween the sequel to
the original Halloween but not Halloween
- and definitely not this other movie
called Halloween - okay wait let me
start over before you see the third
Halloween - that's right in it
be sure to revisit a lloween the first
one not the new one and not the other
movie called Halloween
boy this franchise is a mess this is one
of the messiest title wise yeah well
your franchise needs a flow chart and
there's a really good one of like what's
Halloween to watch depending on what you
like right going on a flowchart like is
Laurie Strode a did she lie yeah pretend
this didn't happen like yeah because
there's four four timelines for house
there yeah there is a there's there's
the zombie time languages off on its own
thanks the corner here there's this new
one the new the new timeline which
establishes that the original movie
happened and then this one that just
came out happened right so that's the
second time where they're the only two
movies the og timeline there's the og
timeline which is having one two four
five six where ruins Laurie died in a
car wreck and all that stuff the fourth
timeline is the Halloween light which
counts Halloween one and two and then
how would each - oh okay
not the druid stuff at Halloween
resurrection yeah so there are four
separate Halloween timelines do we want
to stretch it to season of the witch and
call it five Halloween timelines mMmmm I
think technically when howling is a
witch count inside of the Michael Myers
timeline because it's the this the
Celtic stuff is in there so I've always
considered Halloween three to be in
continuity with the og it was the weird
it's the Chamber of Secrets to the
eventual Celtic rituals curse yes it's
like a weird background thing yeah I
could be wrong I'm sure there have been
some other statements made but that's
that's how I always point is there's a
lot of dumb Halloween movies out there
there's a lot of there's a lot of
different ways to keep track of the
continuity in almost every way that you
want
yeah yeah it's a
choose-your-own-adventure where there's
like one good answer okay keep going
now and everyone is like super horny
then you ripped my clothes off then we
Ripley these clothes off yeah ok JP
joking no it's only us were the only
things on the screen no more picture
trailer we can't see with us it's just
on oh boy let's just keep rolling stop
let the people see button see how the
one is 40 yeah
like super horny first I rip your
clothes off then you rip my clothes off
then we rip Lindsay's clothes off yeah I
think I know you're joking but Lindsay's
a child you creep killers on the loose
and he's inventing or cementing every
slasher cliche you'll get every losers
like wearing a creepy mask making spooky
phobias hashtag influence of targeting
suburban teenagers only letting the
final virgin girl survive and eating
dogs Mars the only one who eats dogs
probably for the best
yeah there's a time line in this movie
of this movie itself it's a little uh
how I say crowded for Michael Myers to
be doing all of these things slow moves
so slowly but then other times so
quickly to find the time to eat dogs be
all around town
well you gotta have a meal at some point
is that way he broke out the night
before yeah he drove 150 mile or 50
miles yeah here's a sketch is him trying
to buy gas yeah because that thing is
not a Prius no it's you got a fake house
together well yeah the escaped mental
patient with no money somewhere there's
either gas station for dead
I think he does switch cars doesn't he
no he kills the mechanic okay and takes
his clothing but he keeps the he keeps
the station wagon the stolen and be
siphoned gas
he might have siphoned gas some car to
the other for that car maybe it had a
gas can in the back of it it was a
mechanic's car
the real brain-twister is to try to
figure out the timeline on when he stole
his mask because he has it in the
beginning of the movie and then when
Laurie and her sister or her friend are
driving to go babysitting the sheriff is
at the hardware store with the alarm
ringing and he's like somebody stole
some knives a Halloween mask which means
that that alarms going off for about
seven hours and they have the slowest
responding police force in the country
which actually would be well do we have
confirmation that that was Michael Myers
that could have been an unrelated
hardware Halloween store robber perhaps
someone else stole you know also the
adults are all leaving this town so
maybe he the the cop was like all the
other cops are off with the rest of the
adults it's an empty city on this day
that's a good joke oh you'll see look is
there a scream - multiple Myers theory
oh there's another Michael Myers yeah
interesting where he wasn't working
alone yeah or like Star Wars is there a
bigger Myers Theory like bigger Luna
well we know that Ben tramer was wearing
his Ben tramer arousal theory yeah take
Luke yeah sorry about that I know I love
I love look up that big Luke fan thing
I'm just saying you know enough time has
passed where he's kind of he's missed
breakfast
yeah he's heading on depending on what
time he unleashed all the mental asylum
patients that might have been before
dinner they were already they were like
free-range like aneroid he released them
or they just like allowed to roam no I
think it's like he he brought some bad
things and everybody just wandered out
the door yeah yeah yeah okay yeah
sometimes you got to eat a dog sometimes
gotta eat a raw dog
to just you know it'll pick me up before
your killing spree
that's the world we live in keep going
so was that Mars the only one who
actually eats a dog's probably for the
best
Jonathan's my favorite reporter Larry
Curtis Greenwave her mom was in psycho
making her a mere screen princess watch
her goody two-shoes Lauri try to survive
the night with her friend Annie and a
whole star of the drinking game take a
shot every time when this says solely
the best Halloween ever you guys you're
totally the blend of the best how to
kill this baby-sitters club is Michael
Myers one of cinema's most iconic
mouth-breathers forget Instagram cause
he's stalking girls the old-fashioned
way standing in clear view of them then
somehow batmanning into thin air when
they're briefly distracted running
sprinting a full sprint yeah he's got
like a he's gonna jump over the hood of
the car start the car yeah this is the
one that people debate because she
doesn't look away
yeah that one's in her head that's
that's gonna live people she blinked
that's how what but Michael is just a
monster made by the film's real
Frankenstein we both appreciate my
psychiatrist with Rekha Stein this grass
of Psychiatry I spent eight years trying
to reach him and then another seven
trying to keep him locked up
who doesn't exactly really messed up
this kid's face at some point pause that
is true let's go the kid is perfectly
not disfigured and then what happened
Loomis happened the Loomis treatment
happened his version of the secret is
messed up yeah like I feel like it was
more of a he stopped even trying after
eight years so he spent seven is what
thirteen fourteen there when he got
Ryung open he stopped trying yeah yeah
that's about a he could be as young as
13 eight years from there so and he says
um he's just been in this in like a
single room yes like he's been in
solitary the whole time and he hadn't
said anything and so like what's Lewis
just been doing like just poking him
with something [ __ ] I feel like yeah
holding his face up against the griddle
and teaching him how to drive allegedly
someone else perfectly well last night
yeah man Loomis is the real the real
villain in this it's kind of a piece of
[ __ ] he did not prevent he certainly did
not prevent Michael might have created
him pretty much cuz this is like the
actions of like a messed up kid who
maybe doesn't know what he's doing
yeah but post Loomis no excuse yeah it
almost makes if the movie like own dad
it's almost more interesting if Loomis
is like I've made a horrible mistake
yeah and yeah I'm just trying to cover
his own ass yep
anyways let's keep going and doesn't
even obey handicapped parking saw along
sir you need an unstoppable killing
machine get fine but you were parked
outside a medical facility sir where is
your placard
yeah so strap we're and with one of the
cleanest horror films of all time from
carpenters masterfully tense directing
and original score to Deborah Hills
razor focused riding in production to
Jamie Lee Curtis and star turn against a
brand new horror icon just be sure to
follow the upcoming sequels lead and
pretend none of the other movies ever
happened
trust us
we went through four clips that all
equally could have been so many days
yeah all involving asteroid my favorite
is the toast made it in the cram it the
the perfectly normal human dialogue that
a human would say that they put in the
script for that toast like they wrote
half of it and then either he forgot or
they forgot to write the rest of the
toast yeah as he gets through half the
toast and then he just starts I don't
know jazz in it just just just getting
scat weren't word just like but not in
the good Busta Rhymes no yeah like the
beginning of any song where he's just
yelling the name of the other squid
flipmode squad members and what year it
is improv it's just complete words out
it's amazing it's like um see like just
freestyle like don't don't freestyle
don't do that yes let's keep going sorry
about the shape of slaughter Laurie
Strode up to the wrong house that's for
sure I'm talking about
yeah jokes are fun people Casey Affleck
old man who knows the town's dark secret
and he kissed his wife and his two
children goodbye the somewhat less horny
but still kind of horny friend and the
mystery creeper in the backseat of this
car while Michael yeah that breaks up
yeah someone else's back of the car from
Loomis and others in Bay 2 my pain it's
right you know what the real horror is
living in a home where your parents only
buy you the kirklands like knockoff
comic books laser man
Neutron man I can understand why
tarantula man worst cinematic universe
ever they're all coming to Netflix yeah
I've always been rewatching I'm always
like come on yeah do one more pass on
those how'd you like to mention drawing
my other eye peas like you can now I
don't say Superman I got in your movie I
don't know if you can but they just felt
a little you know loser man you know at
least like be incredible alright moving
there has been a laser man movie fight
who would win a fight Neutron man or
laser man obviously laser man yeah yeah
well no you have Neutron man Joe well
here's the thing the biggest weakness
for Neutron man and I know I'm throwing
in the towel here is while Neutron had a
lot of really cool effects and I loved
the score the score really kind of
carries the movie and doesn't really
capture the old feel of Ultron so yeah
who could forget the neutron Man theme
yeah you know and they're on the light
bikes it's like it's all badass and the
throwing laser frisbees at each other
and the music's all like womp Wow yeah
perfect Ron alright let's watch some
deleted scene and only targeting
suburban teenagers in fact where are all
the adults in this town no one helps no
one ever calls the cops I guess a secret
druid cult isn't so weird after all yeah
it's very strange when you think about
it where because Michael's parents the
night that he kills his don't uh sister
got gone even with a babysitter
and then two kids across the street from
each other also gone with the
babysitters the parent not a costume
party because the parents are not
leaving in costume hmm where are the
adults of Haddonfield going every
Halloween I think they're in on it and
they're all members of a death slash sex
cult because the cop the copies
Linda's dead or any status the police
says that the cop has been going around
all day with dr. Loomis saying like
there's a murderer on the horse
like he's like oh yeah he's going to
kill tonight him he doesn't tell his
daughter is like hey don't go
babysitting tonight like or just keep a
lookout for any weird large men
wandering around also really reluctant
with Loomis to like like there's the
face of evil coming do some love tonight
chef is like I'll give you ten minutes
yeah but he gives him like all night but
still never takes them seriously like
they spend the day together pretty
really do I want to see more of that
just like because they have remotes and
bracket they're like gathering coffee
like just taking a break
one's a small town copying over how long
have you been a psychiatrist yeah how do
you take your coffee dr. Loomis black
like the dark coming to your town okay
all right I have a site I have a second
theory for where the adults are going in
a field I believe that there is a very
healthy swinger scene happening in that
field and that obviously there's a key
party situation the children do take
after their parents in that way because
if it's a very corny so horndog well
anyone talks about is the potential to
have sex why they're not having sex why
haven't they had sex when will they have
you had too much sex where yeah where I
think that's where they all yeah horny
town party I all I'm saying is I think
Laurie Strode
Michael Myers might not be the only
brother she has in that town I think
yeah cuz the second one there okay yeah
I put it together alright keep God final
virgin girl survived and stigmatizing
the mentally ill as violent threats who
need to be locked away kind of did too
good of a job with that last one
like what jaws did to sharks come on
starring kill him shudder William
stabber slew Lori McHugh large virgin
homicide read the Hippocratic oath and
single and ready to strangled and each
Oakley and definitely stick with a mask
I wouldn't won't you flee my neighbor
sister hacked Keeley on the street
anyone else think it'd be scarier at the
shape was actually Michael Myers sure
fun fact
yeah we're the very first people to have
ever come no one's ever notice that
no we created the joke but then we let
other people have it by cutting it out
of the yes years ago they have a similar
name Mike Myers and Michael Myers the
interesting thing about the two of them
is that they have something are names
and this concludes my podcast
investigation of deep into the history
of it concluded they have similar names
that's the kind of hard-hitting
reporting you can expect I just remember
I remember there was break and I think
it came out on I think I went out on
break well maybe it went out on screen
junkies way back when I started working
here they were doing a what if Michael
Myers was Mike Myers or what if Michael
Myers was Michael Myers supercut while I
was editing Australis remember thinking
how happy I was hopping out and doing a
good job yeah fair enough
I'm not against it I was just glad that
I had other things what the thing I find
funny about it is that anytime anyone
does that bit it's only Austin Powers
yes there's no true there's no shame
Ellie there's no swing there's no love
guru
yes lovely
yeah no Shrek no um Oh sprocket sky yeah
dieter Oh dieter Simon yeah sounds like
there's a lot still to be tapped in this
genre there is of Mike Myers as Michael
Myers next Halloween I think we're the
ones to own it we're gonna make the
Citizen Kane of Mike Myers what if was
Michael make a reaction video to that
yep please everybody amazing the can we
had snake will eat its own tail
yeah and we'll world order guys
vengeance great we will lose the powers
of Sal one I got I got I got corrected
on the pronunciation sorry about that
and Celtic druids mythology and we'll
all get sucked into Stonehenge I think
that's how that works cool cool
all right well just in case that doesn't
happen come back next week where we've
got well we've got a good one next week
oh that's right this is pretty fun oh
yeah sorry
yeah gosh how should we tease this
another foray into the small screen yes
televised yeah a hallmark of our
childhoods yeah no that's not good
enough hint now are we doing keyboard
cat yeah but we're just we can't resist
trying to just think of better clues man
we're gonna need a detective to pick up
the trail yeah yeah that's your clue ah
all right see you here at same time that
that yeah same place new date sure we'll
stick with that bye thanks for watching
you
[Music]